[Música]
ustedes se han preguntado qué hace una
psicóloga analizando políticas
educativas de inclusión bueno es parte
de lo que les vengo a platicar el día de
hoy la experiencia inició con mi hijo
cuando él tenía 4 años de edad hace tres
años
y lo que sucedía era que cuando estaba
cursando segundo de preescolar en la
escuela lo reportaban constantemente de
conducta de situaciones en las que
parecía que retaba la autoridad en donde
no hacía caso sin embargo la maestra
decía yo no sé cómo aprende porque le
pregunto las cosas que se vieron en la
clase y si la sabe
una conducta inquieta de estarse
moviendo constantemente y tener
problemas en el aula porque no se estaba
quieto
sin embargo yo veía la otra polaridad de
mi hijo en casa un hijo que podía estar
absorto durante dos horas armando una
estructura con sus juguetes un hijo que
amaba los rompecabezas un hijo que
ayudaba en el hogar
entonces yo me preguntaba qué es lo que
está sucediendo pareciera que hablamos
de dos hijos diferentes pero esto no era
así yo llegué a la respuesta más pronto
que muchos padres de familia mexicanos
la respuesta tuvo sentido cuando fue
identificado como un niño de altas
capacidades
qué sucedía
que en la escuela no estaba haciendo ni
identificado ni atendido adecuadamente
porque no sabíamos cuál era su perfil
el perfil es muy complejo y es parte de
lo que les vengo a hablar el día de hoy
es un tema relevante
porque si tomamos en cuenta que
estadísticamente 3 de cada 100 alumnos
en las instituciones educativas del
mundo son alumnos de altas capacidades y
no lo sabemos no los tenemos
identificados y tampoco les estamos
brindando la atención que requieren
y otra parte más grave
de acuerdo a instituciones tanto
estatales como a nivel federal en mexico
la estadística es muy clara de cada tres
casos de niños diagnosticados con
trastorno de déficit de atención e
hiperactividad tdh
dos de ellos corresponden a altas
capacidades y fueron mal diagnosticados
esto es muy peligroso porque sucede que
ante los malos diagnósticos existen
situaciones como la que recuerdo en una
capacitación que tuve acerca del tema
donde conocí a una madre de familia de
una niña de 6 años de edad que desde los
4 años le habían diagnosticado psicosis
y la niña tenía dos años que se le
estaba administrando antipsicóticos y el
argumento era cual un exceso de
imaginación y este es el exceso de
imaginación lo tienen algunos niños de
altas capacidades porque digo que
algunos niños porque el tema es más
complejo no hay un perfil único no es
una lista de características o
requisitos que deben de tener sino que
es más complejo que eso
para poder entenderlo me gustaría darles
a conocer un marco de referencia teórico
que es la teoría de la desintegración
positiva de dabrowski y dabrowski que
posteriormente fue retomado por
silverman nos dice que existe
5 niveles de desarrollo pero estas
etapas no se transitan de acuerdo a la
edad como la mayoría de los teóricos
sino de acuerdo al potencial del
individuo y este potencial de los
individuos
se va desarrollando de acuerdo a tres
elementos al factor de la herencia al
factor del ambiente y al factor autónomo
o autoconsciencia que el mismo sujeto va
tomando de sí mismo
pero sucede algo que tiene de positiva
esta teoría cuando nosotros como padres
de familia decimos nuestro hijo está
etiquetado en la escuela como un alumno
latoso como un alumno hiperactivo como
un alumno inquieto como un alumno
etcétera
qué tiene de positivo cuando existen
miles de adultos de altas capacidades
que nunca han sido identificados y peor
aún que algunos de ellos se preguntan y
qué tiene de positivo si yo quisiera
morirme porque siento que no encajo en
esta sociedad y si en es real esto me
recuerda a una experiencia que me
platicó el arquitecto carlos herrera un
poli mata que usa sus dos manos
simultáneamente que puede estar
dibujando con una y puede estar
escribiendo con la otra
y que vivió una experiencia muy terrible
el día que estaba pensando en suicidarse
ese día
él se preguntó por qué no encajo en la
sociedad porque yo quería estudiar
dibujo y mis padres me dijeron que eso
no era una carrera profesional que
estudiar arquitectura y estudiar
arquitectura precisamente para cumplir
con esa demanda familiar sin embargo no
era lo que él quería no encontró cabida
en méxico actualmente radica en canadá
en donde sucedió una situación se quedó
sin trabajo con una hija pequeña y una
esposa que mantener y el motivo por el
que se quedó sin trabajo es porque era
excesivamente innovador porque era
propositivo y porque hacía muchas cosas
que no le pedían
entonces ese día que él pensó en
quitarse la vida
se le vino a la mente una respuesta que
no había pensado anteriormente cuál era
ésta
autoemplearse abrir su propio negocio y
entonces él tiene actualmente una
galería una galería de muchas cosas
donde él expone sus dibujos artísticos
donde igualmente exponen los diseños de
autos de lujo europeos que él ha llevado
a cabo también la joyería que él diseñó
en plata pero también hubo una
oportunidad ante esto que a su hija le
brindó la oportunidad de que ella no
viviera esta situación su hija gwyneth
de herrera que actualmente tiene 10 años
de edad ha sido en varias ocasiones
galardonada en canadá como una de las
mejores artistas desde pequeña
y él ha tratado de brindarle las
oportunidades que él no tuvo y se
dedican a actividades altruistas además
de eso tendrán que ver algo de esto con
la teoría de la desintegración positiva
de la cual yo hablaba bueno aquí viene
una parte importante la teoría nos habla
de cinco factores de la herencia sobre
excitabilidad es se le llama y está
sobre excitabilidad es
las explicó una de ellas es la motriz es
el potencial innato que trae el
individuo para estar en movimiento
constantemente para estar con su cuerpo
en constante movimiento repito y
entonces pues obviamente esto llega a
molestar en las escuelas porque son
niños que no se están quietos porque son
niños que están cambiando de un lugar a
otro que se están parando de su lugar
sin embargo también ellos están
manifestando sus situaciones emocionales
por medio de ese movimiento
hay otras sobre excitabilidad
qué es la perceptual lo sensitiva y esto
tiene que ver con todos los sentidos del
ser humano puede ser la vista puede ser
el oído como lo dije no hay un perfil
único cada caso es independiente y
entonces tenemos niños que perciben
sonidos lejanos que para otras personas
es imperceptible
también tenemos personas que ante
ciertas texturas de la comida
hay rechazo
a niños que les molesta la etiqueta de
la ropa niños que no toleran cierto
calzado y así simultáneamente se pueden
presentar en varios sentidos o en uno
solo
también tenemos la sobreexcita habilidad
emocional y entonces tenemos niños que
buscan un apego a un objeto oa una
persona y buscan cuidarlo y
entrañablemente se encariñan y buscan
hacer campañas ecológicas cuidar el
ambiente
también tenemos por otro lado la
sobreexcita habilidad intelectual y son
niños que constantemente buscan
información quieren respuesta tienen
muchas preguntas
bueno esta teoría no es exclusiva de las
altas capacidades es para los seres
humanos en general lo que sucede es que
los teóricos en sus investigaciones han
tomado como hilo conductor está sobre
excitabilidad es porque se han dado
cuenta que las personas de altas
capacidades tienen la presencia de una o
varias sobre excita habilidades
y entonces con esto podemos comprender
más fácilmente a los niños en las
instituciones educativas
podemos entender a un niño que no se
puede concentrar en una actividad porque
viene del recreo y se cayó su amiguito y
se lo llevaron a la enfermería de la
escuela y él realmente está preocupado
generalmente está llorando así como
puede estar llorando porque se enteró
que existía una perrita laika hace
varias décadas que los rusos la mandaron
en una nave espacial para experimentar
los viajes a la luna
y el niño de verdad puede estar llorando
muy preocupado por lo que le pasó a
laica así como puede estar muy
preocupado y sin dormir porque se enteró
que hubo un tsunami al otro lado de
nuestro planeta
podemos entender a los niños que no
toleran el ruido en el salón de clase y
que les es difícil concentrarse o que
hacen preguntas que incomodan a los
maestros o que los maestros no pueden
responder
esa es la realidad que viven nuestros
niños
sin embargo
por ello es que me acerco a este tema de
las políticas educativas al análisis de
qué políticas existen y cómo es la
implementación de estas políticas porque
las hay en el mundo pero las prácticas
siguen siendo las mismas
y entonces
qué sucede que voy dando respuesta a lo
que está sucediendo con mi hijo
esta experiencia
imagínense la
cuando vemos una curva de distribución
en donde la mayoría de la población está
en la parte central el mayor porcentaje
que viene siendo el 94% y para ello se
están diseñados las actividades esa es
la realidad en todo el mundo
esta experiencia a mí me marcó en tres
ámbitos
primeramente en el ámbito profesional
como lo comento y actualmente en mi
tesis doctoral estoy haciendo este
análisis de las políticas educativas de
los niños como lo denomina la
normatividad en méjico de aptitudes
sobresalientes porque porque las
aptitudes sobresalientes contemplan los
talentos ya sea el talento científico ya
sea el talento motriz o deportivo se
lleva a manifestar en el deporte o el
talento artístico o el talento humano
social
ese análisis que estoy llevando a cabo
es lo que me hizo acercarme a ese tema
profesionalmente
pero también
hay otro ámbito de mi vida
al que me llevó este viaje y es el
ámbito de madre
en el ámbito de madre
en el que también vivo con la
preocupación y la ocupación
de que no suceda con mis hijos una
experiencia como la que vivió el
arquitecto herrera
esa preocupación de que no sean
atendidas sus necesidades
y de que sientan que no encajan en esta
sociedad o en el ámbito educativo
porque hay un paradigma que yo quisiera
que esta charla ayudará para eliminarlo
ellos no necesitan ayuda ellos saben
mucho ellos son muy hábiles y si
necesitan
y hay otra
parte como madre que me llevo a
aperturar un centro de atención para
identificar y brindarles servicios tanto
científicos como a nivel emocional a
estos niños
pero el viaje que me tomó por sorpresa y
que nunca imaginé
fue un viaje personal
que al transitar todo esto con mi hijo
durante estos tres años
me percato como madre que mi hija mayor
que él dos años mayor que él también
tenía altas capacidades y yo no me había
dado cuenta
porque lo que sucede con las niñas de
altas capacidades y está documentado e
investigado y por eso hay campañas de
las niñas en las áreas stem y su
participación en las áreas científicas
es que las niñas
por una tendencia social lo que hacen es
ocultar sus capacidades para que no las
vean diferentes para que nadie se dé
cuenta
y yo no me había dado cuenta que mi hija
tenía altas capacidades
pero tampoco me había dado cuenta
que yo soy una persona de altas
capacidades
con este viaje entendí muchas cosas
entendí porque me sentía diferente toda
la vida desde el preescolar hasta el
doctorado porque quería que las cosas
fueran más rápidas
porque quería que se hablara de otras
cosas más interesantes porque quería que
se abordarán otros temas yo no lo sabía
lo vine a descubrir con mis hijos
sin embargo
lo que me tranquiliza es que como madres
somos muy sabias
mi madre
aquí presente que obviamente no lo sabía
tampoco porque si no es un tema como una
horita mucho menos hace unas décadas
ella hizo lo que tenía que hacer para
que administrativamente me permitieran
ingresar a la primaria y no tener que
esperar me un ciclo escolar porque me
faltaban seis días para cumplir los seis
años de edad que marcaba el sistema
educativo
que hubiera sido de mí si me hubiera
esperado un año más
no lo sé pero yo espero haber aportado
algo con este tema el día de hoy muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
ya
[Música]